Welcome back, master and lady.
Hello everybody!
We are finally here.
Oh my goodness.
We are finally at the finale of Doom 64, finally.
Hello!
5 hour stream?
No!
It can't be 5 hours.
Because I have another stream in 2 hours!
And obviously, didn't you see the title?
The title is...
How to beat Doom 64 Final Boss Tutorial.
So...
I've been stuck on her for a month.
I got you.
I have the cheese.
I have the fresh cheese.
Actually, it's not fresh.
It's been marinating for years.
That's the good stuff.
The smelly bits.
Ah, that's the cheese!
That's the cheese!
Spoiled cheese?
No!
Spoiled cheese just becomes blue cheese.
There's no such thing as spoiled cheese.
Do I understand the stream title correctly?
It's the final boss tutorial on how to beat...
Maidment Phantom!
What?
I'm not the final boss.
My Gou Shijin-sama or Jou-sama would be the final boss.
I'm just a maid.
I'm just a maid!
Gosh!
Stop it.
Show us the...
Read speedrun strats on this boss.
I got you!
I think.
I like my cheese like I like my Oshii.
Age to perfection with great patience.
Yeah, you'll need patience.
Here.
I think.
Have patience with me.
You know?
So what do you mean...
What do you mean aged?
I haven't aged a day since I died.
So...
I haven't aged literally a day since I died.
Ghosts don't age.
It doesn't matter what age you die at.
I...
I'm forever 19.
Good luck with the final boss.
Could I get a happy birthday from the silly ghost maid, please?
Austin, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Austin.
Happy birthday!
Yeah!
After three weeks of my sensory pain being gone, it has returned in full force.
Oh, no, Brandon.
I'm so sorry.
Well, hopefully all the pain that I caused to these demons will get your mind off of the pain that you have right now.
I'm sorry.
If you never age, does that mean you never wash?
What?
That's not the same thing.
What are you talking about?
Oh, my goodness.
Which one am I on?
I think...
This one.
I think this one has all...
Wait.
Hmm.
I think...
This one.
Second to the last one is the one before you died.
Oh, okay.
Minto, are you going to try and go to Aqua Final Main Live?
I saw they announced that today, right?
They may not be a bit suspending, but I felt a huge pit in my stomach seeing the announcement.
Yeah.
I'm so sorry.
It depends on when it is, right?
It depends on when it is.
Starting...
September, I'm going to try and not travel so much.
So...
But, I mean, if it's for something like that, I'm kind of hoping that maybe it will overlap with, like, another trip that I'm doing.
We'll see.
P.K.
Hi, Peter.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Yeah.
That was so sad.
I didn't get to...
You know, I was actually in Japan during Muse's Final Live.
I was there, but I didn't have...
I never got...
I didn't get tickets.
But I actually had to go to the Tokyo Dome area to register some paperwork.
And so...
But it was on the day of the Final Live that I went.
And so I saw, like, all the crowds around Tokyo Dome, and I was just like, ah, that should have been me.
So I didn't...
I didn't get to see the show, but I was there.
I was there.
Just not there.
I forgot to tell you, yesterday was Ace Combat 29th anniversary.
29th anniversary!
Happy birthday, Ace Combat 29.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
That's crazy.
The FOMO.
I know!
I had first-hand FOMO.
I was like...
I was there.
I was watching everybody.
You know, I was gonna say having fun, but they were probably all sad.
So maybe...
Not so much fun, but, you know, they were all there.
Existing.
Thank you for being you.
What do I...
What did I do?
Oh my gosh, I just dropped my pillow.
I have my...
I got my Ayami pillow in the other day.
Oh my gosh.
My dad right here.
Um, that she had one that if you went to the cafe, um, that she had in Akihabara, the Ayami Sensei café.
They were...
She was selling it and...
You had to order it.
So, it finally came.
And...
And, um...
Oh my gosh.
I was looking at Ayami Sensei's fan box this morning!
And, um...
If you're subscribed to Ayami's fan box...
I am not!
I'd like to have seen something.
No spoilers because it is kind of... it is... it is a paywall.
So... I saw... did you see?
She tweeted it.
I wasn't really on Twitter much today because I have been cleaning.
She did tweet it a little... but there's something else in there.
But... I'll retweet it.
I'll retweet it.
There's something else in there.
That is kind of funny.
But...
If you can't afford it, that's totally fine too.
But it's kind of funny.
A b-b-b-bonus?
Yeah... quite... quite something a little silly.
Which I think is so funny.
Especially...
I can't say much because, you know, it's not my right to say.
But it does involve me.
Ayami salesperson.
I just love Ayami.
Okay.
Guys.
It's time.
Level 28.
I'm going to try the cheese.
And cheese I shall.
Do we believe?
It's my birthday today.
I would really hate if you sang happy birthday.
It would be the absolute worst.
Just absolutely terrible.
Would it be even worse if I called you woomy and not woomy?
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear holy .
Happy birthday dear holy.
Woomy.
Happy birthday to you.
It's time.
Come out.
Boom.
Don't do this.
Aaaaaaaah!
Aaaaaaah!
Noo!
Die, die, die!
Everybody die, everybody die, everybody die.
Everybody die!
Everybody.
All of them!
Ouch, shoot.
Ok, time to leave.
Time to leave.
Time to leave, time to leave.
jewelry Chill out!
Chill out!
Chill!
Chill Six, I think?
Yeah.
We're strafing!
We're killing!
And we're killing!
We're killing, guys!
I think we're doing okay, maybe.
We're strafing!
Okay, nice, nice, nice!
Oh shoot!
Okay.
Oh, there's another spider.
Where did you come from?
Shoot.
Oh shoot.
Let's go back to...
Oh my gosh!
Let's go back to rockets real quick.
Oh my god.
This guy.
This big guy.
Got him?
Where's...
Okay, hold on.
Oh, there's another big guy.
Okay.
And we can blow up this guy.
Okay, so far so good.
Sorry, I can't really reach yet.
Okay.
I just have to be in position.
Once I...
Once I take him out.
Oops.
Wait, who's still here?
Okay.
Oh shoot!
Oh, shoot!
This is the strut!
Yeah!
I did it!
Just keep going!
This is the strut!
Yeah!
I did it!
I figured it out!
I got it!
It's not gonna kill him.
But then we switch here.
Yeah!
I
told you it's the strut!
I told you it's the tutorial!
I told you!
Five minutes.
Easy, baby.
I told you it would be five minutes.
Finally, the mother of all demons is dead.
The blood pours from your eyes as you stand in defiance.
As the only marine to endure the slaughter, you decide to remain in hell and ensure no demon ever rises again.
The end.
Thanks for the stream, I guess.
What now?
Oh!
I don't know what now.
Thank you for the Akasuba!
I didn't get to read it, though.
Chido-chan, thank you for the...
Zombieman!
Oh my gosh, we get the whole cast!
Yay!
Zombieman!
Short stream.
Thanks, everyone.
I didn't think I would be able to pull it off for the first try, though.
Oh!
Oh, I shot him!
Shotgun guy!
You wanna watch me take him out?
Yeah!
Imp!
Oh no, he's trying to...
I'm gonna take him out.
We're gonna see his little butthole.
Butthole!
Oh god.
Nightmare Imp.
Woo!
I'm gonna take him out.
First try, first try.
Butthole!
Demon!
Call him what he's called.
That is a pinky.
Pinky!
Pro tip.
To defeat the mother of demons, shoot at her until she dies.
Like a fine-aged Parmesan.
I can't believe... Oh!
Spectre!
Lost!
Oh.
Get out of here.
Cocoa Demon!
That was awesome, Strat, but are you enough of a gamer to go for the true ending?
I want... Wait, what's the true ending?
Did I miss the tutorial?
It's the fastest stream ever.
Hell Knight!
First shot.
First try, baby.
Baron of Hell!
The loading screen took longer than the gameplay.
That's not true.
Arachnotron!
I like these guys a lot.
Pain Elemental.
Kill this guy.
This guy sucks.
Stupid Meatball.
Mancubus!
The way they die is so nasty.
The Cyber Demon!
Me!
Hold on.
Our...
Well, guys, I do have another stream today.
That one will be longer.
I don't know what to do.
Wait, how do I get out of this?
It's the same thing again.
Wait, hold on.
I'm not Shotgun Guy.
Hold on.
Karaoke?
Okay.
We can do karaoke.
Karaoke.
What do I do?
How do I leave?
Main menu?
This re-release has a few new bonus levels that serve as a precursor to DOOM 2016 if you want a few more levels to play.
How do I get to those?
I thought Mint was stuck in the game.
Do I just leave?
Oh, password.
Quit the main menu for now?
Okay.
Pro gamer Minto, looking forward to DOOM 3 when you feel up to it.
Thanks!
I go to options, right?
For the passwords?
Yeah.
What's under more?
Oh, nope.
Under password.
It's six maps, if I remember correctly.
Oh, new game?
I have to do new game?
Oh, the lost levels.
Okay, since I did say I will do karaoke, I'll do... maybe... what?
There's six of them?
Maybe I won't do all of them?
But, uh...
You cheesed so fast that you beat the boss before I got a yummy spin box.
Good job, boss.
Share some of that cheese to us.
We're hungry.
Hmm.
Karaoke while playing the lost levels.
Let's just do... I did bring it on before, right?
So...
We'll just do the same.
Oh, no.
I don't have anything.
Uh...
I have nothing and nowhere to go.
Wow!
Thank you for the Hakka Super!
Karaoke sounds great.
I love the idea of someone turning in for a final boss tutorial and hearing, Giddy Giddy I!
Hey, hey!
Die, die!
Die, die, die now.
Yeah, we'll do karaoke.
Oh my goodness.
Woo!
Hey!
Chill out!
Let's grab that.
I just opened something.
Giddy Giddy I!
You can hide by the line.
Having the better shotgun.
Oh!
I heard someone else.
I think I heard him.
And him.
Grab everything.
Where...
That guy.
Giddy Giddy I!
You can hide...
By the... Hello?
By the line!
Well, it... I mean, seriously?
It was like a tutorial for real.
I think people could actually watch my stream.
And be like, so that's how you beat it.
So...
So funny.
How that...
Aim...
So funny how that just kind of turned out like that.
But I only know because I watched a guy do it.
Wait, can I open this?
No.
I watched this some guy and he was like really good.
Well, I hear someone going...
Where do I go?
Sorry if I'm like zooming through here.
Maybe I go through here.
Oh!
I don't want to go here yet.
I don't think.
Trim and reupload the stream.
For real!
Oh!
Secret!
Is this level zero?
To be honest, I couldn't tell you.
Oh!
Secret?
Maybe not secret.
Where are you?
I hear you in there.
I hear him.
He's moaning and groaning.
That was the classic boomer era.
I glitched the boss strut.
I can't believe it.
I seriously thought like it would take me a couple tries.
But it was just...
It just happened.
I told you guys.
I was...
I cheesed.
Oh!
Okay.
Ouch!
I don't know if I'm supposed to be going this way or what.
Oh!
Here we go.
Alright.
Oh!
Gosh!
There are pain elementals in here.
Or lost souls, I mean.
Ah!
Shoot!
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh!
Not today, sir.
Oh.
No.
That's the wrong thing.
This one.
Always love watching your streams on Kik.
Yeah.
That's me.
Notorious Kik streamer.
Wait.
Okay.
So...
Oh!
This is...
This is what opens.
Oh my god.
Pinkie!
Ah!
Yeah.
Oh.
Uh.
I messed up.
Yeah.
Come back.
Idiot.
I just killed.
I always... I just kill.
I just kill!
Any secrets?
Take some clips.
Stop shooting at me from everywhere!
Oh my god, from literally every angle.
Chill out!
I'm gonna run out of bullets at this rate.
I'm gonna die at this rate.
Can we calm down?
Time to snipe with a shotgun.
As usual.
Where did you guys come from too?
Stop shooting at me.
Everybody's ridiculous.
We need more bullets.
We need more bullets!
I can't snipe from here, I think, you guys.
I think it's a lost cause.
Well, I say that, but you know, it's Doom.
It's Doom.
This level looks fancy.
Yeah, it does look kinda fancy.
Are those the guys that were shooting at me, I think?
Red card.
Ah!
Yeah!
Uh-oh.
I'm gonna be out of bullets real soon.
Uh-oh, I need to use my fir- I'm stuck on the wall!
Uh-oh, I have to use my fists!
Uh-oh.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, thank goodness, thank goodness.
I could've punched him.
I think I could've taken him out.
That guy dropped a shotgun?
Which one?
Oh, this guy?
Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
Legends are true.
Mint guy is real.
Rip and tear!
RIP AND TEAR!
No secret.
No?
No secret?
Um...
I didn't think he'd be camping.
Ew.
Oh!
Anyway...
That's fancy.
Pinky.
Pinky jump scare.
Is this level supposed to just not give you anything?
Is that why it's, it's, uh, you know...
Is that why it's so...
Oh my gosh.
Oh my goodness.
Is that why it's a harder level?
They just don't...
You can't punch people.
Yes, I can, Jackie!
Oh, come on.
Have some more faith in me.
Give me stuff?
Give me nothing.
Yes, queen, give me nothing.
Nice.
Ooh!
Ooh.
Hit hard.
Um...
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Yes, give me everything.
Got him.
Easy peasy.
Lemon squeezy, everybody.
No worries here.
But like I said, since I did say I'll do karaoke...
Um, and...
Honestly, I guess the stream doesn't need to be too long because I, uh...
Wait, where was the blue door?
I don't even remember.
Doesn't need to be too long since I...
Uh...
Have done everything.
Um...
Uh...
Well, not everything.
You know what I mean.
Um...
We'll just do maybe a level or two or something and then...
Then we can...
Then I'll do...
Then I'll sing.
Oh!
Oh, no.
That was the secret door I went through.
Um...
Where was the blue?
Oh, I'm berserk.
I'm berserking out.
Final boss, good luck, man.
Oh!
Thanks!
I needed it then.
I don't need it now.
What am I hearing?
Where do I go?
Am I...
Where's the blue door?
Am I crazy?
Did you guys see a blue door?
It wasn't down here?
Does he know?
Wait, what do I know?
Oh!
Um...
Uh...
Q.
Is it that over there?
That bright light?
Oh!
You are crazy, yes.
I'm crazy good at the game.
Oh, maybe through here.
Oh, hello.
Why are you in here?
Oh, my God.
Why are you both in here?
Where did you guys come from?
Maybe...
Oh, maybe it's down there.
Eating Mike Tyson's butt.
Thank you.
Thank you for the...
Gifted...
Is it down here?
Let's try it.
Let's check this out.
Oh, I got the super shotgun.
Wait, how do I get back up?
Oh, it's like that.
The legend.
Guys?
I think I have no idea.
Wait, there's a door right there.
What?
Looks like you need to raise that bridge.
Yeah, I didn't...
I don't think I missed a...
Oh, maybe it's timed here, right?
No, it's on, right?
Yeah, it's on.
Hmm.
I didn't think I missed anything.
I'm lost as well.
Is there a switch here that I...
Didn't see?
Might be.
Switch here?
No.
Okay.
Oh.
Now I'm all the way back at the beginning.
Another switch panel.
Oh.
Another adventure.
Well, we found the blue door, you guys.
Aww.
We lost...
Here.
Shotgun.
Good.
Can't grab yours.
Give me your clip.
Oh.
Give me your shotgun shells.
There we go.
Already dead?
What a loser.
Wait.
I think I heard a guy.
Did I see one over there?
No.
I think I'm grown.
I think I heard a guy.
I think I'm crazy.
And the yellow key.
Perfect.
Oh.
Don't shoot!
Oh, shoot.
Fine!
Thanks for the 10!
Thank you so much.
Bye!
OK.
What keeps... oh, I got you.
I got it.
Easy peasy.
Did you take your meds?
No.
That's what I have to say about that.
Taking my meds.
Oh, rockets.
Now we go back to this room.
Who just entered?
Did I kill him?
I don't think I did.
What if I just blast him?
Who is that in there?
Oh, I can't blast him.
Okay, let's just run.
This is more than I bargained for!
Why is there a Baron of Hell all of a sudden?
Oh,
no!
They were right there!
Oh my... oof, oof, oof.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, I get stuck up on the walls so easily.
Stop it!
Who is still aiming at me?
Oh, I don't have any bullets here.
Oh, gosh.
Hit the thing!
Oh my god, there's more of them.
Ah!
I'm out of bullets.
I can only rocket launch!
Oh my god.
Yippee!
Rocket launch!
Nope.
Not today.
Oh my god, I think they're too far away.
If I try and... Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, this is such a mess.
Get him!
How did you take a rocket to the face?
Oh my god.
You can also punch them.
They're behind the bars.
There's this guy.
I think I got him.
This guy.
Death.
Maybe death.
Nice rocket.
I only have A left.
Okay, I think I got him.
Oh, I picked up shotgun shells.
Somewhere.
Yippee!
Oh, more rockets!
Maybe they do love me.
Who just entered the room?
Not anymore.
How is this level more stressful than the last level?
They just always exceed my expectations, you know?
Wait, is that a guy over there?
No, he's not moving.
Okay, let's go.
Exit.
Wait, what's this?
Nothing.
This?
Holy moly.
Bye!
Yippee!
Peter, thanks for the membership.
Thank you!
20% secrets.
Oh my god, should I kill him?
Should I take him out?
Take him out from behind his back?
It's so sad.
Look at that butt.
Look at that butt!
That's an imp!
That's an imp we're ogling right now.
And a butthole.
How do I get out of here?
Like, just like that.
Don't try me.
No, do not try me.
I'm a different ghost.
I've beat the mother demon.
I cheese the mother demon.
Do not!
Save?
I guess we can save.
We'll save over level 21.
Wait, oh, no.
What does this count as?
Level...
35!
I hear them.
I hear them doing their ugly whispers.
Wait, was there something here?
Yeah, a chain gun.
Yeah, take that.
Now take that.
They're whispering about me?
They're just...
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
I see you.
Over there.
He's just like, oh, I'm here, too.
I'm late for the party.
Baby.
Nice moves.
Bing you.
Is there anything here?
Why is there just a random...
All right.
Oh!
Ow!
How did that miss?
We got him.
Gaming.
Gaming everybody.
Minto gaming.
Everybody remember.
I hear somebody.
So as soon as we get up here, I know there's gonna be some whispering.
Who is there?
Minto gaming.
Obama?
What?
He has nothing to do with this.
He's not taking my credit.
Maybe it was them.
Maybe they were the whispers.
How do I get this armor?
Super shotgun.
Okay, okay, okay.
I heard it.
Run, run, run!
Yippee!
Secret.
Electric berry.
Is it him?
Was it you?
No.
There's more.
Oh.
There they are.
Uh oh.
Who just came out?
More of them.
Ow!
God.
In fight.
Yeah, in fight.
You dummies.
Oh my God.
There's so much happening here.
What?
There's a spider too?
Oh.
He killed him.
Okay, okay.
I can take him out.
Probably.
That was a little overkill, but you know.
Nice.
They're giving me energy things, but I don't have an energy gun.
Where's my energy gun?
Oh!
Spider squished.
Poor little spider.
I need more shotgun shells though.
Oh, box.
Boxel.
What did that open up?
Anything?
Oh.
I'll take that.
Oh, here, here, here.
Nice.
They say choose one.
No!
This is so unfair!
Do you want the blueberry or do you want the plasma gun?
No!
This is so unfair!
It was my birthday a few weeks ago.
Well, happy few weeks ago birthday!
The ADHD agenda?
Is that what your name is?
Wait, or did that say head?
The head agenda.
The ha- agenda.
There's a spider behind you.
No!
Blueberry all the way.
Oh, we could get a new gun.
This is unfair.
Why are you making me choose?
Only blueberry.
Wait.
Yubi!
So unfair.
Okay.
Oh, this opened up.
The lighting in here is a little freaky, right?
Take those rockets.
Wait, can I run from here to get that blueberry, I wonder?
Oh!
I got invisibility!
Oh, that's what that did.
Fun?
Oh, wait.
What?
Is something lower?
What's the point of having invisibility if I don't know where to go?
Hold on.
One second.
I opened- I activated something.
And...
Is it over there?
Maybe it's here.
I'm partially...
Invisible.
Don't bother me.
Oh, here.
You can't see me!
How can you see me?!
Oh my gosh.
You can't see me.
I'm John Cena.
I'm John Cena!
It's only partial.
No, no, it's real.
It's 100%.
Believe, believe, believe.
Nice.
How do I...
That's how I do it.
Or maybe not.
Oh, God.
Oh, God!
Don't open the door, you guys.
It's scary out there.
Just don't open the door.
I should have changed the chain gun.
Anybody else?
They're like, Haha, you thought it was that lever because it's yellow and the key is yellow.
But no, it is this lever over here.
Dummy.
Get played.
Howdy, Mintopia.
Have a nice day.
Thank you, Dean.
Thank you so much.
Oh, I don't have the red key.
I'm dumb.
I knew that.
Yellow.
Those tricky level designers.
The demons kind of know what's up.
But also, how do they, like, get anything done?
You know?
Wait, I'm stuck.
How do they...
Where was yellow again?
Oh, I remember.
Hi John Cena.
I loved you on Bubble Bee and Suicide Squad.
Hope you have fun hosting Shark Week.
Yes, I knew that I was hosting that.
Thanks for letting me know.
Ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Yeah, get stun-locked, dummy.
There's more over here.
Whoa!
Yeah, get stun-locked, dummy.
Okay.
What's in this area now?
Take all your bullets.
Energy cell for a plasma gun that I forfeited.
Good luck, mint chip.
Thanks!
What's this one?
Maybe it's a...
What's the word?
Rockets.
How do I...
Hold on.
I think I'm...
Oh, here we go.
Wow.
There wasn't an enemy immediately?
As soon as I walked in?
Oh!
Oh my god!
The spitter!
Damn it!
The spitter was right here the whole time.
Blue!
Come on.
There has to be something.
You.
No.
That looks like a trap.
Where's the next one?
What?
I keep putting it.
Weakest trap ever.
Too easy.
Five out of ten.
Oh.
Yeah.
We want this one.
Too easy to determine that it was a trap, you know?
I called it from a mile away.
Whoever designed that one, it was like their first day on the job.
They were like, what if we let...
What if we...
What if it was like a little candy?
Like a...
You follow the armor.
You'd be like, oh yeah, I have to get the armor.
Oh, what am I on this one?
Ah!
Maybe it was his second day.
Oh my god.
There's another spider in here.
Spider demon!
Ooh, piece of candy.
I just keep following it and...
Haha.
Not just one spider demon, but two.
And then three.
Oh my god.
They're doing...
This guy.
They want me to be on this side.
Oh.
Okay.
Are you sure?
What a...
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Oh...
Ouch.
I think I got him.
But there was...
This guy.
With the long hair...
Don't do it.
Don't you do it.
Don't you...
I don't always see them.
I don't want to see your ugly faces.
I don't want to see them.
I can't tell if I'm getting him or not.
What is this?
What is going on?
Oh my god, there's several of them.
There's several of them.
Can we all like fight each other, you know?
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
He's coming in here.
You see, you're not allowed in.
This is private property.
Did I get them both?
Nope.
Oh my god.
Oh, he's still here?
Okay.
Something opened.
But what?
Here?
Oh, wait.
How am I supposed to reach that?
Interesting.
Oh, maybe from back here?
No.
Aim up.
Okay, sorry.
Super shotgun?
No.
Jump.
That's my favorite mechanic in Doom.
Being able to jump, you know?
Really great thing that they added.
A raised platform.
It's over... it's right here, right?
Yeah, I can see it.
I can see...
I don't see where there's a raised platform, though.
Don't see it.
No!
Use the rocket.
What, for the splash damage?
I don't know.
Strange.
It's a little peculiar of a button.
Did I get all of them?
Yeah.
Trying to make sure I got every, like, weapon or...
All the stuff stuff.
Hmm.
Second floor.
Oh, see?
Missed that shotgun.
Okay.
Huh.
You can jump in the newer ones.
That's very true.
They did include that.
Have I gone through here?
I don't know if I have.
I must have, right?
Oh, yeah.
I just missed that rocket.
Cause that's where the line of...
Of the thingies were.
Yeah, I want that.
I see the weapon.
Is that the BFG?
Hmm...
Oh, yeah.
A little candy trail.
I wonder if I needed to have gotten it when this platform was...
I think I missed my chance.
Because this platform was raised.
No!
Dang.
Wait.
Oh, there.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
No.
Which is open.
Oh, wait!
Oh!
Now we can do it!
Right?
Yes, yes, yes!
Hey.
Open up.
Yippee!
Okay.
We got it.
Now...
We have...
What did we just grab?
The red key?
I don't remember where those were at.
The red key.
Well, not here, obviously.
Uh...
We go...
This way?
Yeah.
Yellow key.
Maybe in here?
Have you been here the whole time?
No.
I think you just spawned, right?
Grab all these clips.
As much as we can.
I'm running around.
The speed of sound.
And he was bored later.
Where was...
Was it...
Oh.
I don't think that.
Where was...
It was in here, maybe.
Maybe.
No...
Oh.
Yes.
Uh-oh.
That's a lost soul.
Maybe.
Oh, you guys are jailed because you're all...
You all got caught.
That makes you really lame and stupid.
How did you live that?
Only idiots get caught and put in jail.
You guys just weren't good enough.
Oh, shit.
Oh, it's a bear to help.
Oh, no.
Oh, oh, oh.
I got him.
I got his butt.
Oh, no.
And then as soon as I press this button, we're going to all lower.
And the whole army is going to come out.
I hear them all.
Oh, no.
Can I get them from here?
Nice.
Oh, my gosh.
Where did you come from?
It's like, I've been around.
I've been around.
Let's see if we can get these guys because they will surely gang up on us along with other guys.
Hello?
Please get out of my way.
Maybe that was the last one.
OK.
That's timed.
Nice.
Genius.
Yippee!
Okay,
guys.
I'm gonna do a little bit of karaoke now.
Or do you want me to do karaoke at the Chibi debut?
Which would be better?
Honestly, I have like nothing planned, so...
Maybe we'll just keep this as Doom related and then we can do the karaoke...
during the Chibi debut.
Both!
Look at you.
You're so selfish.
Just kidding.
You want your cake and you want to eat it too.
This one looks sick!
Look at that guy over there!
What a warm welcome.
I want to keep playing.
I will save.
Maybe I'll play these off stream.
Maybe I'll finish these levels off stream.
Or maybe one day if I'm feeling bored, I'll just stream them.
You know, whatever.
But this level has a really cool look.
I would keep going, but like I said, I have another stream in one hour.
And I would like to eat before then.
So, thank you guys for watching me cheese.
People are gonna be like, wow, look at that stream length.
It's a whole hour.
It took her an hour to beat the final boss.
Wow, Minto gaming is not real.
And then, they're gonna watch and see that I beat the boss in five minutes.
Thanks for the tutorial.
Of course!
Of course, of course, of course.
Thank you guys for watching.
Thank you guys for hanging out.
And I'll see you guys in an hour.
If you want to see my new little Chibi model.
It's so cute!
And yeah!
Otsuminto!
And Draco is like, it's from the 20 gifted.
Frog!
Thank you for the Akasupa.
And Gatorap and thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you both.
Both, thank you so much.
And... yeah.
Otsuminto everyone!
See you in an hour if I see you.
And if not, if you're watching the VOD, I might see you in an hour.
I don't know.
Who knows?
In another stream.
You might be watching this and I could be streaming at this very moment.
Maybe.
Who knows?
Bye bye!